hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to powerwall simulator
i've calmed down i don't know what it
was about that staircase that got me so
bad
but it did and i
am actually kind of surprised but i'm
back in the game and i'm ready to give
this another go and i'm ready to be much
more meticulous about it because that's
part of what gets me in trouble from the
get-go is being too quick on some of
these
intricate bits
that require you to really get them
right the first time because if you
don't you're going to pay the price by
going back and forth and back and forth
so i'm going to do exactly that whatever
it is i said i was going to do which i
don't think i actually said anything
that i was going to do
but i'm going to do that
and you're going to join me on the
journey because we're going to finish
this
and if we make good time in finishing
this which i assume that we might i'm
going to probably try to get that rv
done if uh if that is the only other
thing left to do and we still have more
time
[Music]
it's amazing that i still have to learn
these lessons over and over again
like the lessons of
hey be patient be careful be
understanding
be elegant you know be thorough you know
do things how they need to be done
the first time and then you won't waste
time doing them all over again over and
over and over because this game can be
kind of forgiving in terms of like what
is and is not clean but what it's not
forgiving in is
you trying to rush by with a tool that
didn't actually clean it in the first
place and then running around like an
idiot looking for something that is
still waiting to be cleaned expecting
that it'll just uh
glow if you hit a certain button you
know that sign of things doesn't happen
in real life you can't just hit a button
and the the thing that remains to be
cleaned just glow for you it's not how
life works you know
i wish it were i wish it were that would
be
so handy if that existed a button that
just like lit up what needed to be
cleaned but no you know there's no
shortcuts in life there's never gonna be
shortcuts in life so you gotta just do
what you gotta do the first time and do
it right
you know what i mean
i think you know what i mean
i'm wise
i don't know if you guys knew this but
i'm wise this game has made me wise
it's wisened me
wizened me
i've become more wise by playing this
game
[Music]
actually i don't even think that's a lie
there there is i i was talking about
this before and i've said this in a
couple episodes now but there really is
something about learning to be patient
like learning to be patient which is not
a skill that i learned as a kid you know
even throughout my adult life i've
always been very impatient about things
i've always wanted things done
and i've wanted them done immediately as
opposed to
you know taking
really really careful time to make sure
that it's done right
and done because at the end of the day
that's going to get it done
more efficiently than anything else of
like the wishing it was done faster or
wishing that results were there
immediately because
all that
rushing
does
is stress you out
you know what i mean it just
causes stress it's not that the work
can't be hard or uh
require a lot of concentration but you
know doesn't mean it can't be enjoyable
and i do enjoy this
i do
it's a very simple thing but it is very
nice
and i know it's all fake ones and zeros
i definitely know that but
still
doesn't mean that it's not fun
just because something's not real
doesn't mean you can't get some
enjoyment out of it
heck half of the human experience is
just made up [ __ ] anyway so
don't knock it until you try it but also
why isn't this table done this table
should be done
there we go and then sometimes things
are just [ __ ] and decide not to be
done when they should be done but that's
okay
that's why i have infinite patience
[Music]
well that was awfully early but i'm not
going to complain yes some of these
items have their tolerances turned way
down
which i appreciate
i do not complain
[Music]
okay
so that's those now i just need to make
sure i get all of these rails done right
which requires a little bit
of
careful carefulism that's the official
name that i'm gonna use for it and
everybody who doesn't agree with that be
quiet
[Music]
i just had a thought
if i make sure that i get the inside
from this angle and this side then when
i get the outside so long as i go the
opposite direction i should hit it all
and i won't need to turn around and
catch these because this is a waste of
time
i could do these
technique
interesting
that could work
[Music]
suddenly railings aren't as bad as i
remember them being
ah
[Music]
that is if this works if i get to the
other side and i'm not and i don't
complete a single rail then i'm going to
be very mad because i'll have to go
through it all again but if i make sure
that i get it all from this side
it should be good i'm going to get this
i'm going to win i'm going to win
[Music]
i've got a darn pattern for rails now i
can't believe it down the bottom up the
pillar
down across
down up down and then the whole thing's
done
from the side anyway
up across down up down
easy simple
and the thumps are still happening yeah
maybe bigfoot will be happy i'm cleaning
his tree house
he should be pretty excited as far as i
know
like why wouldn't he be why wouldn't he
be grateful why wouldn't he take a
selfie with me why wouldn't he let me be
his biggest fan i don't know
maybe he's an [ __ ]
[Music]
i think the what makes this game so
appealing is kind of the repetition like
i don't like chaos too much
that's why i don't like going back and
hitting things again and again
i like feeling like there's a consistent
thing that i can do
and if i do it right
i can get consistently better at it
and that's what really hits the
satisfaction
not to mention like the cleaning part of
it the cleaning part is very nice
but there's something about in the
repetitive motions
and like the expected results because
that's what i always hate in in games is
when you do something and it's not
exactly what you expected it to be but
if you get down like a pattern like this
it's exactly what you expect it to be
and now theoretically the entire inside
rail of this upper level
is done except for the tops oh damn i
forgot about the tops
but i might have to get those
[Music]
okay and now that's that so i just come
around here i pick a spot to go first
looks like this is it and then i do the
exact same thing i just did except now i
have the addition of the baseboard but i
just sweep up i sweep across the outside
is very much dirtier
holy crap the only problem is gonna be
moving this stupid thing over and over
again
[Music]
ah i'm gonna not like this stairs i knew
that no matter what this would still be
a pain in the ass
and i'm gonna make this jump
okay there we go
thank you
it is still meticulous work and uh no
this is how i lose time
stand on the rail and stay no stay
stay the slip and slide of this game
[Music]
do
hmm
[Music]
oh
what did you just do what are you doing
i know you weren't done done
whatever i'm not complaining
i swear i'm not complaining if he wants
to give me partial credit i will take
partial credit gladly but just as i was
starting to enjoy myself it decides oh
now we're going to give you full credit
oh okay
okay okay all right whatever you say
oh okay i wasn't done but whatever
get out of here get get me get me out of
here
give me this that i yoinked from across
the stars
blam blam
i'm very strong
also don't think i haven't noticed the
gravity is a little lower than it should
be we never have decided that we were
actually on earth you know that hasn't
been established we were doing the whole
mars rover maybe that's just a blast
from the past instead of being
something from the future
you know what i mean maybe that was an
ancient relic that needed to be cleaned
off because it was left to
die in the martian soil in the only
preserve where we hadn't terraformed it
and we're actually on mars
could be
you never know with this thing
i also realized there's an underside to
this that i have not gotten
ah
that is what was missing right
[Music]
okay i guess that's done
the joist however is not done and i know
that and also i am aware that i seem to
have missed a spot on one of the other
rails on the other side
i will address that issue when i have
time to worry about it okay never mind
it's done
i'm a god except this is not done
i'm not a god
[Music]
i'm assuming that the underside is what
this needs
which it may or may not i'm not 100 sure
[Music]
okay well that's done and that's done
okay
all right okay
that's that
now i need to get this part
[Music]
now it's getting fun
now we're getting into the
the nice stuff i'm actually very very
glad oh hi their scent is very much like
that of a muskrat and they seem to
crouch right down when marking their
territory to appear much smaller than
they really are how much small are we
talking here muskrat small
i don't believe that all this is a red
herring i believe that people here seem
stupid but that's just because of the
volcanic fumes that are getting to their
brains
in reality this place is a land of myth
and legend
and i'm the only one keeping them from
insanity if i can just clean a little
better
their minds will
regain their senses and they'll be able
to talk
about all the crazy happenings going on
here would not be surprised if this was
a culture of people that threw people
into volcanoes
i'm just gonna say that straight up
would not surprise me
what am i walking over why is this so
goddamn humpy why is this stupid tree
trunk gotta be so humpy why is the
ground gotta be so bumpa lumpy
why can't there just be some goddamn
consistency
are you guys not done how are you not
done how is any of this not done
[Music]
how are you not done look how done you
are look at the doneness
look at the dunyan
it's so done
how are you not done
[Music]
how's it not done
i can see the water pattern it's all
done
it's
clearly all done
there's nothing there's legitimately
nothing nothing
[Music]
how
are you
not
done
[Music]
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry oh i'm sorry
even this joist is not done
how is it not done
how in the world are you not done
i don't even know anymore
i don't even understand that
okay i'm guess i'm
done trying there there's no way that
that'll ever be anything
i guess
i don't understand you but whatever
not my job this is too high up i mean it
is my job but you know i'll try to
assume that it's a bug
because that's a little redunk
[Music]
oh that's gonna get done when there's
like clearly so much left but this
middle section of this
underside here
no
no no no there's one
millimeter-sized little splotch there
you can't see it but it's there oh it's
there and you missed it oh you
definitely missed it there we go and
that's done
i'm gonna do the jump technique
the jumpest technique
the technique of jumping
i swear i've i'm gonna i'll do it
meticulously i will
[Music]
just be done
give up
to let go go towards the light
go towards the light middle deck
underside
go towards the light i literally did
everything you have
[Music]
so when i come up here to try to punch
you in the face that's when you decide
that you're gonna be done huh because
you're afraid because you were afraid
and you should have been afraid okay i'm
not going to leave it up to chance for
these i guess no i gotta get the thing
and do the thing
oh no
well this is just a nightmare what's the
best way to go about this i have the
long
you'd think that this would be enough
but it's not but maybe it is
huh
tree
[Music]
aha it is enough okay
okay
we are in business so long as we can be
very meticulous
[Music]
oh yeah
we're getting it guys
we are getting this
this is definitely a job for the turbo
blaster
[Music]
hmm okay
i need a slightly better strategy than
what i got right now the problem is i
can get like the center
of these but the sides fall away
so maybe if i just focus on hitting the
center first
and then oh come on
and then when i do the the middle
sections i focus on the inner and outer
portions of it portions of it
oh that's nice
oh that's so forgiving and nice
oh that's lovely
so kind so loving
so understanding of all the hard work
i've put into this
okay almost done
almost done 91 percent
[Music]
i've kind of just gone for turbo mode
because honestly i was going slow anyway
and i had to go over and everything a
little bit at a time so i thought man
might as well i mean i know i could get
the stairs and i could just remove it a
bunch but god i just don't feel like it
i just really don't feel like it you
know i just don't want to do that
[Music]
some of these i need to get this
but i can't fit it there hmm
just because the angle is revealing that
there are several of these pockets that
just weren't obvious to me before
but are very obvious when you get to the
right and i'm off
[Music]
now it seems obvious
oh are they not oh
oh
they're not all the way attached
[Music]
okay
i mean not that that justifies still
crap but whatever
oh see there's like a gap no wonder i
couldn't get in there from the ground
okay it looks good but i know that
there's a lot missing aha
okay so
lanterns
of all the things the lanterns aren't
quite ready
huh
all right
lanterns it is
[Music]
here comes the dreaded 99 percent of
incompletion
where are there more lanterns
where are more lanterns
oh here we go
i would have missed you
all right that should be all the
lanterns okay we got window frames and
signs how are all the signs not done
and are all you window frames not done
you escape me you think you can escape
me
okay window frames are done signs signs
are not done
why
what other sign is there
oh this sign
one of the first things i did i didn't
get balance step upper deck rim joints
vertical house trims all right let's get
the house trims i don't know what the
balance steps are
that's one
as to who
oh that's three okay upper deck rim
joints
upper deck upper deck rim joist right
here this one this one's gonna be a bear
because how do you get to it
aha okay that's one
okay balance steps what are the balance
steps what does that even mean balance
steps
these things
my god that one sucks
but i did it
you don't even get to see the glory of
the underside but damn that one was a
[ __ ]
and i have so much money but to do what
with there's nothing else to buy
no equipment that i could get i mean i
could buy buy buy
but i would have no reason to go back to
the other washers because
we're pretty much full up we're pretty
much full up my dudes we have bought
everything there is to buy and the only
thing that i see left is this
recreational vehicle and maybe we'll
just save that for another day but we
have done pretty much every single one
of these
besides this recreational vehicle but
that is all for today so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope
you've been enjoying this series i don't
know if there's much left to power wash
besides this and i don't know if that's
worthy of another
uh video however there is challenge mode
best wa oh best water oh interesting
best time is fascinating you do get a
glass and you get a metal cleaner
you know what let's let's give this a go
i just i'm just curious three two one
oh man
let's go
metal first
uh-huh
just trying to clean the metal
okay and then go i don't know why i'm on
the ground
[Music]
interesting interesting
none of the windows are done come on
glass cleaner do your goddamn thing
[Music]
do the damn thing already
how is glass cleaner not cleaning the
glass
oh it's plastic
oh
oh the whole body's metal i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot hang on let me try that
again no no no bail bail how do i bail
restart here we go
let me try that again let me try that
again actually let's do glass first
let's make sure we actually get these
glass things clean
come on bumper
oh my god
okay 328 i didn't quite get gold but
that's okay i did my worstest i could
have done way better than that
definitely definitively that's okay
anyway maybe there'll be another update
with more challenges and more stuff to
watch but thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this have
a good day check out my other videos if
you want or
just uh go play a video game go play
this video game thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you